sein lebenstraum ist nur noch asche
lothar es aus klein jena sammelt und
restauriert seit jahren liebevoll
oldtimer traktoren
doch jetzt zerstörte ein scheunenbrand
alles kann man normalerweise eigentlich
bescheiden ja das ist das was ich mal
mein lebenswerk
ja und ich muss das altersvorsorge das
sind die werte das extra turnverband die
scheune mitten in dem kleinen ort
brannte komplett ab
75 einsatzkräfte der umliegenden
feuerwehren und rettungsdienste taten
zwölf stunden lang ihr bestes standen
mit drehleiter und 17 weiteren
fahrzeugen in dem kleinen ort in
sachsen-anhalt und trotzdem lothar s 10
schmuckstücke darunter ein lanz bulldog
eine brockenhexe ein aktivist
alle sind im feuer zum opfer gefallen er
war gerade zu hause angekommen eine
tasse kaffee ein stück kuchen seine
lieblingssendung wollte er sehen
da hörte luther es die sirenen unser
eine riesige rauchwolke über dem ort
aufsteigen
als der ehemalige landmaschinenschlosser
von seinem haus um die ecke in die
nächste straße lief traf ihn fast der
schlag kommt ist so rasend schnell
gegangen scheune ist steht seit 1886 und
das hält das alles toppen konnten preise
da ist es war
nichts jetzt fahren um sich zu retten
nur die umliegenden gebäuden
sie machten damit der kampf nicht
übergreift
wie es dazu kam ist ihm unerklärlich er
gehe aber nicht von brandstiftung aus
und obwohl die 140 jahre alte scheune
gegen brände versichert ist sind die
traktoren ist nicht besonders tragisch
drei von ihnen waren bereits verkauft
und sollten bald von den neuen besitzern
abgeholt werden
auch die scheune war schon an einen
nachbarn verkauft
der übernimmt sie allerdings trotzdem
luther es ist merklich getroffen aber
ins grübeln alles es ist so wie es ist
und ich muss jetzt noch das beste machen
was ist schöner dass man das spiel auch
gegen feuer und alles was uns weil es
die versicherung schließt sich auch
nicht an das war einfach ja und da bin
ich erst mal öffneten seite mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren